okay so this just in when you get sucked
into a video game ish world you don't
always end up in the Mushroom Kingdom
Tron Legacy all right so I've heard
about a Tron sequel literally for years
like over a decade and it's finally here
and is it worth it I'll list off a few
things while I keep you in suspense so
the gist of the movie is Kevin Flynn
Jeff Bridges from the first movie has
been missing for 20 years now and while
trying to find his father Sam Kevin
Flynn's son has been sucked into the
computer world that Kevin Flynn has
created the guy probably has a god
complex by now yeah sure and this world
is of course 3d with a lot of reason
blues like this welcome to the grid
where he then finds out that his dad's
been hanging out with this hot computer
chick for the past 20 years yeah mystery
solved dude it's Olivia Wilde I probably
wouldn't come back either
well that and his father's doppelganger
program turned against him and he's now
all sorts of evil yeah you know the
little things like that now first of all
I got a touch on the 3d by now 3d is
absolutely overused it's in everything
I'm surprised we don't have like 3d
breakfast cereal that would blow your
mind wouldn't it but for Tron Legacy I
felt like they used the 3d in the way
the 3d should be used in the movie when
you're in the real world no 3d you get
sucked into the computer world all sorts
of 3d a gimmick yeah sure but it was
cool it made the 3d mean something you
know if you could just not think of Spy
Kids 3d when it happens yeah I'd kind of
kill the effect and the soundtrack by
Daft Punk went with this movie perfectly
so what was the movie good I actually
thought it was really cool everyone
who's screened the movie says that it's
just fun to look at it's just a shallow
movie and it's got nothing else and in
that the movie was kind of under hyped
for me I actually enjoyed it a lot more
than I thought I would
is it the deepest movie ever no but I
suppose it's a matter of perspective I
for one thought it was a really cool
movie that actually had a couple of
those moments you know those moments
that are like hits me where I live man
yeah those moments like the special
effects in the original Tron nowadays
they are dated so if you've seen Tron
lately and thought to yourself do you
they should totally remake that that
would be awesome they did it's called
Tron Legacy although it's the sequel but
still and I like the villain I liked
clue and clue his evil Jeff Bridges for
those of you who are wondering why I
keep seeing clues here's what would
happen to Kevin Flynn if Kevin Flynn's
ambition made him turn to evil his
personality I liked the CGI and come on
it's a post avatar world or at least a
post Gollum world he didn't look that
great if you're gonna make CGI people
you got to get
on this so the look of CGI bridges
no but props to his personality plus
there were a couple of character issues
there is a character that was absolutely
wasted in terms of who the character was
they had an anti climatic exit from the
movie and that was crap it was one of
those moments it's like the whole thing
was just kind of forced just don't have
it in the movie so Tron Legacy was a
cool badass movie with really good use
of 3d and I can't say it's entirely
shallow or at least as shallow as people
say it is not the deepest movie ever but
it does have themes one of which being
the consequences of what happens when
you become obsessed with trying to
achieve perfection so if you're a Tron
fan or a videogame fan or a person who
just likes to kick his feet up and have
a really cool badass movie then you
probably like me and I would say I buy
this movie even on blu-ray in fact I'm
going to buy it on blu-ray
now I'm not above liking artsy movies
but if you're an over-the-top artsy
person like that
it's a too legit Foles type of person
you probably will not like it but I'm
really not a movie snob so there it is I
just wish they showed more of the games
I wanted more disk throwing this
was badass but if you like what you've
seen here and you want to see more you
click right here to see more user